-Guys, you know every week,
we like to bring you
some uplifting, creative videos,
whether they come from
quarantine or just
stuff around the country.
It's time for
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
-♪ What are you doing
on Wednesday? ♪
♪ What are you doing on
Wednesday? ♪
-First up, this guy got
pretty bored in quarantine
and discovered an amazing
Siri trick.
-Hey, Siri.
[ Phone beeps ]
Change my nickname.
-Okay. What would you
like me to call you?
[ Phone beeps ]
-HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA.
-You would like me to call you
"Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey"?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, that's Mr. Hey, Hey, Hey,
Hey, Hey to you.
Next up, this girl was going for
the perfect rope-swing picture.
She had her buddy
all planned out to get
the good close-up slo-mo shot.
Well, it didn't go as planned.
Check it out.
-...2, 3...
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Did that just [bleep]
And, finally, this baby sister
is not having it
with her brother's crying.
-[ Crying ]
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.
That is "What Are You
Doing Wednesday."